bluewater beautiful beaches and good
food draw millions of tourists to Greece
every summer tourism makes up a third of
the Greek economy but now that income is
in jeopardy many vacationers are
canceling their holidays because of the
euro crisis by contrast Greece lacks
industrial muscle there is little in the
way of machinery construction high-tech
or the production of consumer goods Rhys
accounts for less than 2% of the euro
zone's gdp for years now the country has
been receiving bailout loans Greece has
been living beyond its means after weeks
of negotiations the latest bailout
installment won't be paid it's growing
ever more likely that Greece will have
to leave the eurozone dr watson ah
Joseph feel like a madman the eurozone
made a major error and assuming that all
eurozone countries would do their
homework to restore stability and feel
Anna financial Greece has had problems
since March 2010 and back then they
should have said let the Greeks out for
their own benefit so they can do their
homework we've been delaying this
insolvency for more than five years from
among the common currency was introduced
on january first 2002 by promoting
European unity the euro was supposed to
ensure stability back then the President
of the European Central Bank struck a
hopeful note alpha nomadic deviating
open markets will serve as a catalyst
for further integration shown but there
are rules for example the Euro states
aren't permitted to exceed certain debt
benchmarks but most of them have in 2014
13 members of the eurozone including
Germany had more debt than the sixty
percent of GDP allowed under the
Maastricht Treaty only five states met
the criterion set down in the document
that laid the groundwork for the euro as
a result of the current crisis in Greece
many are now demanding that Europe
Institute a joint economic policy that
includes
unified taxation insolvency regulations
and even an EU finance minister but so
far the eurozone states haven't been
able to reach an agreement Germany is
one of the countries that is benefited
most from the euro relatively low
currency exchange rates have boosted its
exports more than twenty percent of all
German exports go to the EU countries
the Netherlands exports thirteen percent
of its goods within the EU France just
nine percent Greece lags far behind at
0.4 percent countries with higher
revenues pay more into the blocks budget
to support those who have less revenue
so either way Greece will continue to
benefit from the EU